- Let me break it down
very simple for you:
The world plays in the
middle and all the action
is in the edges.
(upbeat music)
You've got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
Melbourne, what is up.
(cheering)
What is up?
Fuck, I've been flying for two days.
(laughing)
But I'm here and I'm excited to be here.
Thank you for having me.
Thanks for the warm welcome.
So there's a lot of places I want to go
with today's talk.
And so, let's just get right into it.
I think, for me, what I
really want to accomplish
in this talk today is set
up a framework of strategy
of how much abundance
and opportunity there is
right now and why.
And then, number two,
really get into the tactics
that I think a lot of people here can take
and take whatever
they're trying to achieve
to the next place.
I think the thing that,
as I was getting ready for this trip
and I was really looking
at a lot of the things
on Facebook, and Instagram, and Twitter
and other things of that nature
that have become such an important part
of the way I think about the world.
But, more importantly,
before we go into that;
what I was doing over the last month
as this kind of conference
was coming together was I,
are you really wearing a
Patriots fucking shirt?
(crowd laughing)
Jesus.
Just completely took my
energy to a different place.
Just wanna punch that dude in the face.
(laughing)
As I was getting ready for this talk,
what I was really looking at were people
that were making references to it
and then kind of going
down the rabbit hole,
especially, on the flight
our here after I caught up
with all my work and still
had 20 hours of flying.
As people were referencing
this conference,
I was able to kind of
go into their accounts
and take a look at what they were doing,
how they were doing it.
And what's become really
remarkably interesting
to me over the last
half-decade and, especially,
over the last couple of years
is how many people hear
me, understand or consume
a lot of the content,
but are unable because
of patience, I guess,
or many other reasons;
how many people's actions don't map.
I mean, literally, the amount of people
that I'll post something about something,
they'll jump in and be like,
yeah, Gary V., you're right.
And then, I click their
account and they're
literally doing the complete opposite.
In that hypocrisy, in
that misunderstanding,
in the white space, is really the thing
that matters to me.
I think the first thing
that everybody needs
to really wrap their head
around and understand
about this era is how much attention
is really being put here and how much,
if you're not winning on this devices,
how much vulnerability you have.
Number two, really understanding that
we talk a lot about
content but nobody here,
including me, with a humongous team,
and this is super-important.
This is really what I wanted
to start this talk with
because I think it will help people.
Me, with a team of 20, putting out between
80 and 100 pieces of
original content a day.
I'm grossly underperforming
in the amount of content
I put out every day.
To really set the tone for everybody,
the volume, the sheer
volume of content needed
for every individual or
business in this room
to be successful in a 2019 environment
is staggering, and nobody's really making
the financial, or mental,
or emotional investment
into that level of content.
The amount of people that are super-fine
with putting one or two pieces,
or three pieces a day on one platform
are just leaving an enormous
amount of opportunity
on the table.
And so, for me, if there's
anything that I can get
through today, and there'll
be plenty of things
I'll try to get through.
But the sheer amount of content needed
to take full advantage of
this land grab is staggering.
And so, that comes in a lot of forms.
For me, the reason I'm so
obsessed with people focusing
on video is because the
reality is that video
creates a scenario that
allows you to do images
and written words and audio
on the back of filming.
For me, the reason I do a vlog daily
is because we're able to use
that as a top of the funnel
piece of content and then I'm
able to produce a podcast.
I'm able to produce the,
quote, pictures you see
on Instagram, the written
articles on my .com
and LinkedIn.
It is the top of the funnel
that creates everything else
instead of bottom-up.
It's unbelievably important.
If you're fortunate enough to be here
and you feel okay to be
in front of the camera,
you need to lean in.
You need to absolutely lean in.
I think there's a lot of people,
and by the way, I'm a big
believer that you have
to bet on your strengths
and be self-aware.
I think there's a lot of people here
who wish they were
something and the reality
is forcing that is their vulnerability.
If you're not comfortable being in front
of the camera for whatever
millions of reasons,
or whatever insecurity, that's super-fine
and you should lean in to
audio on your phone or,
if you're a great writer.
You need to figure out
how you communicate.
But let there be no confusion here today.
If you are not producing
content for the internet,
you are basically
nonexistent in our society.
If you have, regardless of
how good your B2B business
is doing, or how great
you're real estate firm is,
or financial service.
Sears was winning, too, at one point.
Regardless of how well you're doing,
you are vulnerable right this minute
because all of the
attention, on a daily basis,
continues to funnel here.
And whatever excuse you come up with,
which is my audience is not on there,
or my industry isn't affected;
all those things become
your great vulnerability.
I recently, just a couple of weeks ago,
completely changed the strategic
and creative foundation
of where VaynerMedia,
my company, is going.
And a lot of people in my inner circle
pushed against it because they're like,
we're doing well.
And I reminded them.
I'm like, look, I'm desperate
to put us out of business
before somebody else does it for us.
How many people here are having
their best financial year
personally or in their business?
Raise your hands.
Let's clap it up for them.
(audience applauding)
One more time, raise them high.
No reason to be embarrassed about that.
Keep them up.
To me, the people with their
hands up in that scenario
are the one that I'm more worried about
because, when it's going well,
is oftentimes when
people become complacent
or they don't think the
thing matters for them.
And so, for me, those are the things
that really, really stand out.
I think the other thing
to really pay attention to
is attention itself.
For me, attention has been the thing that,
bless you, that I've
chased my whole career.
When I was selling lemonade,
I would look at poles...
Did you just get naked, bro?
Shit's getting crazy here in Melbourne.
(laughing)
This row's fucked up.
The Patriots fan, the naked dude.
I hope they paid extra.
(laughing)
I just looked over.
Dude's like fucking naked.
(laughing)
Attention has been something
that I've been chasing
my whole career.
Selling lemonade against, you know.
Really, what's interesting to me,
it took me about four or five years ago
when I finally realized it.
I wasn't setting up the
tables or making the lemonade.
I was really spending all my time looking
at the cars and trying to figure out where
to put the posters and the
signs to get people's attention.
I did that in baseball
cards and I did it in wine.
And I've done it, pretty
much, my entire career.
And I think the thing that a lot of people
need to focus on is
where is the attention?
So, for example, 24 months ago,
I would not stand up here and
push LinkedIn very heavily.
You know, the platform was
pretty much for anybody
that understands LinkedIn
and has been around it.
It was really something where
people put up their resumes.
It was something that people
really spammed each other on.
LinkedIn became a shitty
place for all of us
because all it was was
people emailing in bulk
with no context.
And then, about three
years ago, four years ago,
they made it more of a content plane.
You started seeing a little bit more.
And they had some influence on it.
And I was on it and it was fine.
But over the last 18 to 24 months,
it's been remarkable how much opportunity
there is on LinkedIn.
And if you're in this
audience and you're doing
B2B marketing, and you
do not have a LinkedIn
content strategy, you're
making a humongous mistake.
Because when you layer on
top of it ads that allow
you to target the titles
of the occupations
that you're trying to reach.
How many people here are in B2B.
Raise your hands.
I mean, it's an enormous
percentage of this audience
and I continue to watch B2B companies
not create original content for LinkedIn.
And when they do, they're
much more in a commercial
or sales-oriented way, not in a branding
and create content way.
I always tell people if you make content
on the internet as if you're the TV show,
not the commercial in between the TV show,
you will get disproportionate
return on your investment.
The problem is most people are looking
for instant gratification and
return on their investment.
The amount of people here
who've run a thousand dollars
in ads on something, it didn't work
and they deemed it as it doesn't work
is staggering to me.
I have spent millions
of dollars on Facebook,
and Twitter, and Instagram, and Google
that haven't worked.
I've also spent millions of
dollar on those platforms
that have worked.
The execution of the
creative is the variable
in that environment.
Just because you ran $1000
or $10,000 in Facebook ads
and it didn't work, it might
be the picture or video
that you put in front of people sucked
and didn't compel them to buy anything.
The attentions under-priced.
There is no doubt.
The attention's massively under-priced.
I built my family's wine business
on under-priced attention,
on email and Google AdWords.
Those were the early 2000s.
I know what it looks like.
It's exactly what's happening right now
with Facebook and
Instagram and influencers.
They're just under-priced.
Pre-Rolled podcasts, under-priced.
There is no debate that the
attention is under-priced.
There's a reason that
Wish, the shopping app,
does 6 billion dollars
in revenue on the back
of 98% Facebook ads.
It's under-priced.
But are you capable to
create contextual creative
at scale, that's the question.
Can you produce 97 pieces of content
for 97 different demographics
and psychographics
and then run ads against
them to compel them
to buy you're things.
If I'm selling sneakers, which I do,
there's going to be a
fundamental difference
of the video or picture
I'm going to put in front
of somebody who's 18, white
male, in New York City,
versus a 47 year old Latina
woman with two kids in Texas.
The problem is, when
auditing the 30 accounts
that I looked at, and
the hundreds of thousands
I do a year, 99% of people
make one to five pieces
of content and run their ads
and expect something to happen.
It is fundamentally not
contextual to the audience
that they're trying to reach.
Very simply put, everybody,
everybody's running creative
ads, media, marketing right now
as if it was 1997 and
the only options you had
was the newspaper, the
billboard, the radio,
and the television.
Meanwhile, we have
Facebook, and Instagram,
and influencers that allow
us to go way more long-tail.
The problem is people
haven't put in the time
and the effort to create the
content that's contextual
to the psychographics and demographics.
So, and I'm going very fucking nerdy
because I'm fucking fired
up right now on this.
I think that every person in here,
regardless of what they're trying to do,
whether they're trying to run for mayor,
raise money for a charity,
or sell their services,
needs to have at least
13 to 30 core audiences
that they produce content for every time.
So, literally, every time you
have something new going on,
you have to create 30
variations where the copy...
I mean, you could target
people who are divorced.
You can target people who have two kids.
You could target fuckers
who like the Patriots.
(laughing)
You could do so much.
You can do so much with this medium.
Yet, people are mailing it in.
Meanwhile, they're also having ludicrous,
there are ludicrous conversations going on
like people having ego around
how well they do organically
on these platforms when the
ads a massively under-priced.
Do you know how many people emailed me
crying that Facebook's
organic reach declined
three years ago as if
Facebook screwed them,
while Facebook is, literally, free to use?
Do you know how many
people here are starting
to get concerned that they're not getting
as many likes and views
on their Instagram account
because they can feel
something's happening?
Yet, it's free.
I really need to drill this home.
People are mad at the
algorithm on Instagram.
They run ads everywhere else.
They buy a booth at a conference.
They run print.
Direct mail, costs money.
You start an Instagram account,
if you don't run ads, you can
organically build an audience
and you post.
Now, you're mad that you're
not reaching as many people
and you've got this big conspiracy anger
at the algorithm, yet you
haven't paid a fucking dime
for the platform.
(audience laughs)
That guy drank that beer quick.
(laughing)
It's a very intriguing thing for me
that people have emotional
opinions about something
they haven't paid for.
And so, here's the game and
it will always be the game.
Things come along, they're under-priced.
Real estate, stocks, attention.
When they're under-priced,
you need to strike and
squeeze as much as you can
out of them.
I will come back to Melbourne in six years
and spend my entire talk
trying to get people
to stop running ads on
Facebook and Instagram.
That will happen.
It's always happened to me.
It's the same old game.
You take advantage when it's under-priced
and you squeeze it as long as you can.
You ride it all the way through.
And, eventually, the long tail catches up
and it becomes overpriced
because companies come in,
because of the bidding,
and normal people stop
paying attention as much.
Everybody here who's been on Facebook
for five-plus years pays
attention to every piece
of content on Facebook a
little less than they did
five years ago.
Or maybe a lot less.
That is just the natural
cadence of what we do.
How many people here had
email in the late 90s?
Raise your hands, old fuckers.
(audience laughs)
So all the people that
just raised their hands,
what they can tell everybody here under 30
is what we used to do
with email in the 90s,
which was we read every single email.
Wine Library's email service in 1999
was almost 90% open rates.
How many people here
have done email marketing
in their career?
Raise your hands.
90% open rates.
It's ridiculous.
It's like 32% now and I think we feel
like we're heroes.
So that will happen with these platforms.
So, look, before I get into the mindset
and the strategy and
some of the social things
I'm seeing going on, I'll
go back into the details.
But the details are very simple,
and I said it when I was here last year
and I'm going to say it again.
If you are not a practitioner yet
of making content and running
ads on Facebook and Instagram,
you will massively regret it.
And the reason, and you've seen me say it
in every video, I am
putting it down on film
to recall it in a decade.
I will never stop saying it.
I don't care how much
you're tired of hearing it
and hoping for something new.
I'm not going to make up something
that isn't true.
They are grossly under-priced.
The one little add-on
that I've been saying
a lot more over the last month or so
than in the past is how much
content you need to produce.
And the reason one of the
breakthrough videos I've ever made
called, Document, Don't
Create, worked is it's hard
to create a new video that's creative.
That's hard.
But if you actually film your day-to-day,
your meetings, your mundane,
there's absolute action in that.
And so, I'd highly recommend
really understanding
what that means.
Let's take a step back
and let's talk about
something I've been
spending a lot of time on,
which is, in a world where I'm asking you
to create so much content,
the fact that so many of you
do not create content
because you're so bent
out of shape by the feedback
in the comments section.
This has become a remarkable
fascination of mine,
that people literally
aren't living their lives
to their happiness or their fullest
because SallyPants36 said
that you're ugly or fat.
(audience laughs)
People absolutely crippled
by the judgment of others
without really understanding what it is.
Let me say it here right
now so there's no confusion.
If a human being takes
the time out of their day
to consume your piece
of content, consume it,
and then spend time to leave
a negative comment to you
after consuming your content,
think about how shitty
that person's life is.
(audience murmurs in agreement)
Somebody literally has the time to consume
your content and try to drag your down.
My friends, misery loves company is one
of the most interesting
sayings that has been
in culture for a long time.
It most manifest in a very poor way
when I watch parents drag their kids
into shit because they're upset.
But it's one thing, and I have empathy,
a lot of it when it's your mom and dad
dragging you through
shit, because that's deep.
But when an anonymous
person with a fucking icon
of a rugby player is
dragging you through shit,
you have to get into a place where that
does not bother you.
It makes zero sense.
I mean, literally, and I
get shit on all the time.
You get that many
comments, you get shit on.
When I see it, I don't feel bad for me.
I genuinely feel bad for them.
I'm fascinated.
I've never in my life taken the time
to consume somebody's content
and then shit on them.
It makes absolutely no sense.
So, please, if you're
one of these individuals,
and there are a lot of
you in this audience
that are no producing content
because you're worried
about the judgment.
You know how many people email me,
Gary, but I have to put on makeup.
Why?
Because your grandma told
you when you were seven?
But, Gary, the lighting?
Why?
You don't like the bags under your eyes?
Good news.
Everybody has bags under their eyes.
Like, there is an enormous
amount of insecurity
in the system that is stopping people
from creating the thing that they want
and it needs to be talked
about in a much bigger way.
The judgment of others
is a fascinating thing.
How many people, by show of hands,
work in a job and are
desperate for their side hustle
to become their career?
Just raise your hands.
Raise them high.
Can you stand up, actually?
I need to see this because
I've got to get a sense.
Stand up if this is your MO.
Your side hustle, you're
desperate for that
to become your career.
Good amount.
Okay, thank you for doing that.
So I'll go into this.
So this has become a new
thing that I've been spending
a ton of time on;
something I've realized that
really kind of caught me
off guard is how many
people spend more money
on shit than they can afford.
And I know that's like
a funny thing to say.
But it's actually very basic.
I'm actually talking
about the amount of people
that have emailed me
in the last six months,
because I've been on this rant lately
of trying to get people to
move back in with their parents
at 30 and 40.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, I'm hot on this.
It's because there's
this incredible thing.
How many people here own their home?
Raise your hands.
The people that just raised their hands,
90% of people that own their homes
don't use more than 50% of their home.
They have three extra
bedrooms that they don't need.
They have a living room, and dining room,
and a fucking den, and all sorts of shit.
The amount of people who live in homes
that they've extended
themselves financially to afford
that don't even use half of
that home is fascinating.
The amount of people who are
in debt so they can drive
a car that has a logo on it
that makes them feel better
because that's keeping up with the Joneses
or other people's judgment
is fascinating to me.
What I didn't realize was that fact
that 35-fucking-percent
of this audience wants
their side hustle to be their careers,
but the reason they can't
is because they can't
quit their job because they need their job
to pay for dumb shit to impress
people they fucking hate.
(laughing)
(audience applauding and cheering)
And so, especially, while
the economy, globally,
is frothy, I am aggressively throwing up
for debate for the third of this audience
that is trying to get their
side hustle to be their job,
for them to give a real thought
to what it would look like
if they were to downsize
their home, and their car,
and their vacations, and their watch,
to put themselves in a
position to be happy.
I think, over the next decade,
as we continue to start
really discovering,
as a human race, mental
health and happiness,
that we are on the
predawn of people changing
what success looks like.
When I really look at the world,
and I grew up super-humbly.
I've spent my 10-years-ago
career in the explosion
of Silicon Valley.
I've really been lucky to see
all sorts of different things
going on.
It is super-cliche but absolutely true
that the money/happiness
things is just a funny thing.
People that don't have it
think it does bring happiness.
People that have it know it's not true.
And when you really look at suicide data
and depression data, it's
fascinating who struggles
with it.
I really do believe, as
we become dramatically
more thoughtful about
happiness versus money,
that a lot of people are going
to really start looking at
the things they amass and how much that
is a choker to their happiness.
And so, what really excites me right now
is how frothy the economy is globally.
And I know so many of
you can take advantage
of selling high, positioning
yourself to be happy.
I think it's a very rogue point of view.
It's completely against the propaganda
that you see in your Instagram
and Facebook feed 24/7;
everybody's pushing all
sorts of fancy stuff,
and fancy trips, and fancy things.
I genuinely believe that
the majority of people here
can dramatically,
dramatically put themselves
in a happier place if they, honestly,
considered downsizing
things that they don't use.
So just a random thought that
I'm super-passionate about.
Let me talk to you guys
about influencer marketing.
For me, I talked earlier
about under-priced attention
and overpriced attention.
The way you get those
things is when the market
doesn't understand itself.
When people don't understand
how under-priced Facebook is,
they don't put money into it,
thus, the prices stay down.
The most inefficient and
misunderstood marketplace,
in my opinion, is influencer marketing.
Humans don't know how to price themselves.
There are pretty people
that have 400,000 followers
on Instagram that want $30,000 a post.
And they're are other
people with 5,000 followers
who want $40.
They are 400,000-follower
people that want $100.
They are people with $500
followers that want $5,000.
The inefficiency in influencer
marketing is staggering.
How many people here, by show of hands,
and you guys have been pretty
bullshit-y with your hands.
I don't know what's scaring you.
But go high.
How many people here sell
an actual product, physical?
Raise your hands.
A lot.
Every single person, one
more time, hands in the air.
All of you, all of you that
have your hands in the air
should have a significant
influencer, thank you,
influencer marketing strategy.
Literally, DMing people on
Instagram and asking them
how much they would charge
you to take a picture
holding your physical product
and tagging your page.
It is massively inefficient.
I love when people, Gary,
how do you scale it?
By DMing more people, fuck-face.
(audience laughs)
It just, there's no machine or algorithm.
Just get nice and cozy and DM people
and ask them one by one if they're willing
to do it.
I often find that the
biggest upsides often
is scaling things that are not scalable.
Scaling things that are not scalable
comes from sheer effort and time.
And so, one more time, I just
want to get the physical.
Selling a product physically.
If I was your partner, buddy with the hat,
selling physical, I would spend 30% to 50%
of my overall marketing budget
on influencer marketing.
It's so inefficient.
And if you're lucky enough
that your product you sell
directly on your Shopify or Amazon,
like, you can see it,
you don't even have to guess.
You literally, one, either codes,
or just isolated time slots
for certain influencers
and you can see what the
return on the investment is.
There's been many
influencers that we bought
that we weren't sure, and
then we bought 50 times over
because their audience was converting
because they had an authentic audience.
I couldn't be more passionate about it
and it is wildly under-priced
in this market down here.
It's under-priced everywhere
but we've even debated
opening a VaynerMedia office in Australia
just on the back...
(audience applauding)
Just on the back of,
really, influencer marketing
because it's so underserved
in the marketplace
and I highly recommend you
take a deep look at it.
Another thing that is
unbelievably under-priced
in this market and globally is keyword
and AdWord Google searches,
and then retargeted on
YouTube Pre-Roll video.
So imagine a scenario where
people search on Google
for curtains, or a financial advisor.
How many people here have
done Google advertising
in their careers.
Raise your hands.
Perfect.
So a lot of you know it was an
incredibly powerful platform
because it was intent-based.
If they were searching for it,
that means they were interested in it
and they would convert.
And a lot of you did
extremely well with it
because it converted highly.
Much easier to be good at Google at first
than Facebook at first.
Facebook is branding.
Google is selling.
Very different game.
Selling is a hell of a lot
easier in the short term
which is why people like it.
Branding and marketing takes time,
which is why people bail on it.
The problem is Nike, and
Adidas, and Coca-cola,
that's branding.
Our bullshit business, this is selling.
Do you understand?
But there is a combination
of selling and branding
that is super-powerful and
it plays out on Facebook,
but it also plays out on YouTube.
YouTube, for everybody that doesn't know,
is the second-biggest
search engine in the world.
For people like me that
can't read for shit,
when you want to go on YouTube and hear it
or watch it visually, you understand it,
it's incredibly powerful.
But besides that, what's
unbelievable is there
is a way for you to actually target people
that search on Google for something...
Let's use my old world.
They search for Margaret River Cabernet
on Google to buy.
Three days later, they go
on YouTube to watch a video
of how to hang a picture on their wall
and the Pre-Roll YouTube video goes,
hey, are you in the market
for Margaret River Cabernet?
And then, you're like, holy
fuck, they're spying on me.
(audience laughs)
Because you fuckers forget
that you searched for it
three days ago on Google.
For me, when I thought about this talk
and coming here today,
I said to myself, look,
there's three or four things
that are just black and white tactics,
that if I get people to actually do,
they will feel benefit.
It's funny how I think about marketing
no different than fitness.
People are always, always
far more interested
in finding some rare fucking
fruit deep in the Amazon
that they can eat that makes them lose fat
than actually fucking working
out and eating healthy, dick.
(audience murmuring in agreement)
Like, you're far more excited
to buy some fucking pill
that was found in Saturn and brought back
than you are to do the very basics.
It's super-stunning.
Eat healthy and work out every day.
It's super-basic but
nobody wants to actually
put in the work.
I've literally spent the last 30 minutes
giving you three to four basic things
that are real as fuck.
99% of you, even though all
of you wrote little notes,
are not going to do shit about it.
You're going to write it down.
You're going to say, yeah, you know what?
I've heard him say it a bunch.
This is the time.
I'm definitely going
to go back and do that.
And then, next Thursday happens
and something good or bad
happens in your business
and you completely put
this talk on the shelf.
Let me be very clear with you.
In October of 2018, in Australia,
if you run Facebook and Instagram ads
against 30 to 50 different
pictures and videos,
against whatever you're
trying to accomplish
in your business, it will work.
Let me make it perfectly clear for you.
In October 2018, if you
spend five hours a day
going to direct messaging
influencers that could possibly
sell your product and
getting a third of them,
8% of them to agree to
post a picture holding up
your product and tagging
your product, it will work.
Let me make it perfectly clear for you.
In October 2018, if you
run Pre-Roll YouTube video
against search queries
on Google of whatever
you're trying to do in
this room, it will work.
Now, I just need to ask you
why you're not doing it.
Because if you've come to this conference
to see me speak, you've heard
this shit 40-fucking-thousand times.
(audience laughs)
I can't wrap my head around it.
I can because I watch it every day.
It's human behavior.
I see it.
But the reason I get
passionate to keep doing this
is I've learned sometimes
it just takes that 19th time
and you actually sitting
in the audience to do it.
Bless you.
What really, really shocks me, though,
and what really excites me as being in,
like, this is my spiel in America,
the most advanced, competitive market
for all of my concepts.
The fact that everything I just told you
is disproportionately
even more exciting here...
The reason we opened
up a London for Vayner.
The reason we're opening
up Singapore next February.
The reason I keep going
global is it's like going
into a fucking time machine.
It's working better here.
It's cheaper here because
the bigger companies here
are even slower than the
big companies in America.
So the big money's not in.
You need to take advantage of this.
You are going to regret it.
You're gonna regret it.
And let me tell you this.
This is a good segway.
An incredible random fucking
thing that I can tell you
to do is to go volunteer
at a retirement home
one day this year.
A very random thing that
can fundamentally change
your life business-wise.
Let me just not even go human.
In your business, is go and
volunteer at a retirement home
once for five hours.
Let me give you the preview
for the 99.9% of you
that won't do that.
You will see human beings
with regret in their eye.
And I promise you, for whatever
scary shit you've seen,
abuse, murder, the scariest
shit you've ever seen,
there's nothing scarier
than to stare a human being
in the face who understands
she or he fucked up
and there's no going back.
Regret.
There's macro- and micro-regret.
Macro-regrets of who you married,
what you didn't do, dah-dah-dah-dah.
And there's micro-regrets.
And, in the context of this talk,
the micro-regret in a business
world is you're sitting
on a golden goose.
It will take you five to
seven hours to Google it
to figure out how to run a Facebook ad.
And, please, Melbourne,
please do me a huge favor.
Do not hire your 22
year old niece and think
she's going to know how to do it
just because she grew up with
this shit and you didn't.
I love what you, Gary, but you know,
I didn't grow up with this shit.
Neither did I, dick.
(audience laughs)
I'm 42.
I didn't grow up with this.
And let me tell you something else.
You didn't grow up driving
and you figured that out.
This is something you have to learn.
You want to have a business?
You want your side hustle?
I love when people, do
people understand how hard
it is to live your live
for yourself on your terms
and make money?
Have we had the right
conversation yet about this?
To live as your own boss
and make enough money
to have a good life, that's a 1% thing
in our society, and everybody
has this level of entitlement.
And, especially, now.
Trust me, I'm feeling it.
I'm the beneficiary of it.
But now that we've made
entrepreneurs cool,
the whole thing's totally fucked.
Everybody thinks
entrepreneurship is so easy.
This shit is super-hard.
It's super-hard to be good enough to make
that kind of money,
Because, even though the internet is here
and everybody in this room
has the chance to do it,
the problem is the internet's
here and everybody here
has a chance to do it,
and supply and demand takes over.
I love people who are
like, Gary, but my content,
it's not doing well but it's
because people don't get it.
I'm too ahead of the curve.
No you're not, Ron.
You just suck.
(audience laughs)
You're not ahead of shit.
The market is the market, is
the market, is the market.
You have 39 views on your YouTube,
it means you suck.
It means it's not interesting.
Or, it means that you're early.
So many people are like, Gary, I'm lost.
You're not lost.
You're 27.
You've just started.
This is a long game and the
opportunity is substantial.
But there are two very important things.
The world, my friends,
let me break it down
very simply for you.
The world plays in the
middle and all the action
is in the edges.
The world plays in the middle.
It's what school does to us.
It makes you in the middle.
All the opportunities in the
extreme of micro and a macro.
I always talk about
macro-slow/micro-fast, right?
Micro-speed.
I work 17 hours a day.
I'm booked every minute.
Micro-speed.
Yet, I'm in year nine
of building VaynerMedia,
in the prime of my career,
not making that much money,
as much as I could, to build a machine
for me for the next 30
years in the macro-slow.
All of the action is in the edges.
Having ridiculous blind confidence,
equally having the
humility to know that you
don't mean shit.
Going all in and having the
ability to completely pivot
if you know it's wrong.
There's such a fine line between
perseverance and delusion.
It's such a fascinating
thing for me to watch.
And so, my friends, I promise you,
there's so much abundance.
I hate watching people get
upset when other people win
without realizing how much
abundance is in the system.
Nobody on earth's success
is coming at your expense.
Everybody thinks this is a binary game.
It's just not.
There's so much abundance.
And so, we, in general, in the macro,
have to desperately
get our mindsets right.
We are collectively,
stunningly, not patient enough.
Everybody wants it tomorrow.
We are unbelievably
lacking in perspective.
The dumb shit that I hear people
complaining about every day
is stunning.
Everybody here needs to
start joining more nonprofits
and getting in the field.
You go join a nonprofit
like Charity: water,
and you go to Africa,
and you watch people walk
seven and a half miles
every day for fresh water,
you start struggling to
complain to the barista
because he or she put the wrong
milk in your fucking coffee.
We need perspective, we need passion,
we need patience, we need a lot of things,
and then, you have to let it play out.
Everything I've ever done, two core things
have always been the theme.
And for anybody who's dreaming
or thinking differently,
I really need you to hear this.
Everything I've ever done professionally,
two things have happened.
One, it's taken forever to
manifest because I was early.
Number two, nobody agreed
with me and people snickered
and made fun of me every time I did them.
If you're looking to innovate
and do something special,
you have to recognize exactly
what's going to happen,
which is the voices, the
voices are going to be the game
that you have to play out.
The one that's become
most fascinating to me
over the last year because I
get so much interaction on this
is the people, and I'm
just going to say this.
This is completely just random.
But I'm hopeful it might
help just one person
in this audience.
If the voice in your own head says to you
that you suck, I
desperately need you to know
that somebody put that voice in your head.
If the voice in your head
tells you to yourself
that you suck, somebody put it in there,
and you have to understand that.
Usually, your fucked up mom,
(audience laughs)
but you have to wrap
your head around that.
Because it's really
difficult for me to watch
so many people not act
based on that own voice.
The biggest thing that
people aren't acting on
is they're not taking risk
because they're scared
to lose and they're scared to
then have people judge them
on that loss.
It is remarkable to me
how easy it is for me
to see a true-bred entrepreneur
versus one that's not.
A true-bred entrepreneur loves to lose.
It is scary to me how much I love losing.
Publicly.
Love my investment.
I love talking on passing on Uber twice.
Love it.
I love when people literally
leave comments like,
don't listen to this guy.
He passed on Uber twice.
And then, I look at their account.
They have nine followers
and they fucking suck shit.
(audience laughs)
And I'm like, yo, bro, but
I didn't pass on Facebook,
and Venmo, and Twitter.
What are you doing?
You're fucking playing
Fortnite and jerking off 24/7.
(audience laughs)
Anyway, I'm obsessed with losing because,
something that I really
want people to wrap
their head around this, when you lose,
it's your loss.
We have so much judgment out
there and we lack context
and laugh when people tell people how
to raise their children.
You're not in that person's home.
I laugh when people talk about
other people's relationships.
You're not behind that closed door.
I laugh when people give advice
on how to run a business.
You're not in it.
If you notice, the biggest
reason I stay very macro
and just give details on what you can do,
is there's so much judgment
being thrown out there
to everybody and nobody knows shit.
Everybody's running around
with judgment and nobody
knows shit about what's
actually happening.
Judgment is poison, my friends,
and this world right now,
because of social media,
specifically, because you
can see all the judgment...
I love when people think
social media changes us.
My friends, social media exposed us.
Nobody's changed.
You used to be a dick, too.
(audience laughs)
You just said it to yourself
and three other people
in your neighborhood.
Now, you can say it to
everybody publicly online.
It's like money and fame.
It doesn't change you.
It exposes who you actually are.
And so, we're living in a
very transcendent world.
And so, you're either going
to look at the negatives
or the shortcomings or
you're going to look
at the positives.
For me, I see all positives.
I love that we're going
through all this shit globally
with ourselves because
we needed to be exposed
of our weaknesses.
One step backward, two steps forward.
That same machine, do you know
how many people say to me,
Gary, I don't think
Facebook and Instagram,
that stuff doesn't work.
Yet, in the mouth,
during that same dinner,
all they talk about it how social media's
fucking up the government, or countries,
or the world.
Literally, you're telling me
that Facebook's powerful enough
to change the global
world and governments,
but it's not powerful enough to sell some
of your T-shirts, or your
landscaping business services?
My friends, take it for what it is.
We are all obnoxiously
fortunate to be living through
this era right now.
What this era is, just to quantify it,
is we are now at the
maturity of the internet.
The internet now is at scale.
We all live there.
It is real.
It's not what I grew
up, which it was coming.
It is here.
It is at scale.
And the reality of the situation is,
how many people, one more
time, with side hustles?
Raise your hands.
Stand up again.
Side hustle to turn into your business?
I need this because this is the point.
I just need every single
person that's standing
to understand one thing:
Your grandparents couldn't even dream
to turn a side hustle into their business
because the internet didn't fucking exist.
They just had to eat
shit and live their life
and put food on the table
and a roof over their head,
and then fucking die.
I'm being serious.
We are so outlandishly
fortunate to have this era
and what everybody's doing
is spending all their time
deploying cynicism and
looking at the things
that are negative about
it without realizing
it is the full empowerment
to whatever you want
if you're willing to be a practitioner
and actually learn this
shit and execute it.
This era will go away.
Many of you follow me, know
I'm all focused on voice,
and Alexa and all this.
It's all going to happen.
Shit changes.
Whether it's blockchain,
or AR, or VR, or voice,
this internet era, this golden era,
as we stand here today, will go away.
And then, for the same
reason that I didn't make
any fucking videos for five years
because I had nothing to say,
there won't be a great
deal like influencers,
and Instagram and Facebook,
and you will deploy regret
because you've heard me
pound it down your throat
and you did nothing about it.
So, please, Melbourne,
do me a fucking favor
on my 37-fucking-hour flight to get here.
Please make this event, this talk,
the time that you
actually go home and start
fucking executing.
Because I'll be very honest with you.
I'm fucking tired of the thousand,
1000 emails every week that I get
that are the same exact thing,
titled, I don't know why it
took me four and a half years
of listening to the same
shit to finally do it,
but I'm really glad I did,
because in the last seven months,
I've made $80,000 and before
I used to be $40,000 in debt.
Please make tonight the
beginning of the next chapter
of your life.
Because when it goes away,
I'm going to get quiet
and execute, and you're gonna wish,
you're gonna wish you did
something about it tonight.
Thank you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Let's do Q&A.
- [Man] We're not done yet.
We're not done yet.
Did you guys learn something?
Very good.
Turn to the person next
to you and give them
a high-five and say, I'm glad he came.
(cheering)
- Stop giving high-fives
and go fucking run some ads.
(laughing)
Let me tell you something.
They didn't learn shit.
If they follow me, they know
this is not about learning.
I pounded this for fucking two years.
This is about doing.
This is fucking exercise.
You know what to do.
You still eat cupcakes, fatass.
(laughing)
- [Man] Got it?
- That's what's going on here.
Fuck.
(laughing)
Seriously, though.
By the way, just to give you a preview,
I'm a nice guy now, or if
you think cursing is mean.
But I'm a nice guy if you look under it.
I'm going to be very mean in four years.
When everyone's crying about this,
I'm going to be jumping in a be like,
you fucking ass, I told you.
I'm going to be razzing
the fuck out of people.
(laughing)
Sorry.
Go ahead.
- [Man] Question number one,
this came from people that are
in the audience here today.
So these questions are from you all.
First question is from Henry Vela,
a question about gratitude.
What do you do when someone
gives you an opportunity
and you know you'll never
be able to pay it back?
- You know, Henry, you've got to take that
as a gift, right?
And the reality is you
don't know that you'll never
be able to give it back.
This is what I always talk about,
how dangerous envy is
and not having context.
I always tell people, the amount of people
that throw lucky or other things at me,
I'm like, look, sure,
but what about tomorrow
if my daughter gets hit by a bus and dies?
Am I then lucky?
And I know, I know,
but that's how I think?
For Henry, you don't think
you can give that person
anything back today.
That's just not how life works.
You might be able to.
So, A, accept the gift and be grateful.
Try to help other people in ways you can.
But if you're so fixated
on helping the person
that put you on, recognize
that life ebbs and flows.
Who's winning today loses
tomorrow and vice versa.
It's a fucking marathon and
everybody's just judging today
without understanding tomorrow.
I spend all my time anticipating tomorrow.
That's the rant that I
just gave for 45 minutes.
So that's how I think about it.
- [Man] Yeah, very good.
Next question: What is you number one tip
for growing a wealth and
investment advisory firm
in the digital age where
access to information
is so easy?
How do you get to be number one?
- Number one comes in
all shapes and sizes.
I mean, to me, it's just
a process of aspiring
to be great.
I think it's about, for me,
where the information's free,
it becomes, especially,
in wealth investment
and things of that nature,
it becomes a personal brand world.
People buy from people.
That's just the way it's always been.
And so, the more, and by the way.
The biggest reason so
many people lose in legal
or wealth or things of that
nature is they front, right?
They play a character on social media
not who they actually are, right?
And so, as you can imagine, in 2008-2009,
I missed out on 90% of
my speaking engagements
because I cursed.
It was less acceptable than it is today.
I still do but I didn't
know how not to be me
and that was just the
way it was going to be.
I think a lot of people
try to be the person
in their LinkedIn profile
even though they hate
wearing a fucking tie.
And I think the more you can be yourself
and just talk about the
things you're actually into;
there's more people that would
get business in this country
talking about footie than
talking about the actual skillset
they have in managing someone's money.
It's a personal game.
- [Man] Inside of there, if I
can just ask you a question.
You said something.
You said the process of
aspiring to be great.
But I think that's so powerful.
Where does that come from for you,
the process of aspiring to be great?
- I just love my game.
I love my game.
I don't want to win because
I want to keep playing.
I never want it to end, right?
Once you find what you
love to do, you've won.
And so, for me, I'm
trying to get better at it
all the time but I'm not
fixated on being number one,
or having the most money or revenue.
I'm just in my own little insular circle
just enjoying it and
trying to get better at it
and letting the chips fall.
I mean, it's incredible
how little I know about
anybody else that does anything that I do.
I've never watched anybody
give a talk in my life.
I've never read a
business book in my life.
I've never listened to a complete podcast
of anybody's podcast.
I'm sure they're great.
I'm sure you enjoy it.
I love that.
I watch sports.
I'm not saying that you shouldn't.
It's just not my process
because it doesn't matter.
The only thing I care
about is the audience.
And so, that's why I read all my comments.
That's why I have insights on this,
why I got into places
like empathy or judgment.
Once you understand that
somebody knows everything
that they should be doing,
you have to ask why they're not doing it.
You start getting into
mommy and daddy issues.
You start getting into insecurities.
You start getting into
a lot of people here
not building personal brands
because they have skeletons
in their closet and, once they get public,
they don't want to deal
with the ramifications.
There's real shit out here.
(audience laughs)
I always enjoy the
skeletons in the closet.
People get really weirded the fuck out.
People's faces get funny.
(laughing)
- [Man] Next question comes from Veronica.
How do you get in with the right people?
For example, if you want
to get in with the people
who choose the light bulbs
for the next multi-billion dollar hotels.
- Yep, Veronica, you have
to reverse-engineer people.
It's really easy.
You know who the
decision-makers are by title.
Follow them on LinkedIn,
Facebook, Instagram, Twitter
and see what they care about
and if they're into things
that I've talked about already.
Footie, or Margaret River Cabernet.
That is your gateway.
There's a reason people play
golf or have steak dinners.
They get to know people.
They get to know their spouses.
They get to know things
that make them tick.
And then they exploit them,
if you want to go cynical with it,
or they just use them to do business.
But Sarah who makes that
decision is the person
that you need to reverse-engineer.
And so, one of my favorite
things about social media today
in a B2B environment
is following the people
that you want to do business
with and figuring out
what they love.
And then, if, to me, I
think manipulation's scary.
So, for me, I'll never,
when I know something
about somebody, make
pretend I like it too.
I'll look for the things that
I have a common interest in
and I'll lean in there,
or I'll have a teammate
that has a common interest,
or I'll just reference that interest,
just showing respect that I
understand what's going on.
I think too many people fake.
People try to do that to me all the time.
They're like, Gary V, yo, the Jets, right.
I'm a big Jets fan.
I'm like, name the offensive line.
They're like, oh, fuck.
I'm like, fuck you.
(laughing)
So I think you have to
be careful to fake it
for the sake of business
which is why I always
bet on authenticity.
And so, but you can
reverse-engineer that person.
- [Man] Yeah, very good.
Next question comes from Shermaine.
What's the best way to
support teenage kids
who have an entrepreneurial
mind and limited assets?
- Well, limited assets
is the best fucking thing
for any entrepreneur.
I mean, I don't know how
people haven't realized it.
Here's the secret: Adversity
is the foundation of success.
This would scare me a lot more if they had
an entrepreneurial mind
and had tons of assets.
Entitlement and too much abundance
creates zoo animals.
And so, to me, take more away from them.
(laughing)
I mean it.
And definitely don't dwell on things.
To me, I think the thing
that my mom did really well
was she saw that I was entrepreneurial
and she doubled-down on it.
And she punished me for bad
grades but she didn't make me
feel like that was the most
important things in the world.
And so, I think finding
a balance of raising
a child with entrepreneurial aspirations,
finding a cadence between
them respecting things,
but also leaning in on their strengths.
But it's interesting that the person
put limited means.
It means that they're
feeling some insecurity
that they can't give
their kid a $10,000 boost.
That's the best thing that happens.
Put a kid out there that has to learn how
to eat for themselves.
The best thing that ever happened to me
was when I rolled up on
my mom in fifth grade
and I was like, mom,
everyone's getting Nintendo.
I was Nintendo.
She looked me dead in the face
and, with her Russian accent,
she said go buy it.
So then, I fucking shoveled
snow and fucking raked leaves
and washed cars and sold lemonade.
And from a very young age,
I learned how to make money
for myself.
I genuinely think entitlement is poison.
Abundance is poison for entrepreneurs.
I genuinely think restrictions, limits,
and lack of resources are the foundations
of the best entrepreneurs.
- [Man] Yeah, very good.
Next question comes from Chris.
He says how can I take my indie comic book
from being a small-scale
project into a large brand
that more readers will
care about and enjoy
just as much as I enjoy creating it.
- Chris, I think there's
a couple of things.
One, first of all, you have to understand,
the market is the market.
And so, for me, two
things that I would do.
One, if it's good, I'm blown
away by how many people
get mad at doing free work.
All these creators get mad at free.
It's so laughable.
I always do shit for
free and will continue
to do things for free
because it creates leverage
and context.
So what I would do, Chris,
if you can afford it,
and if you couldn't afford
it, have a side hustle
that lets you afford giving
away 3,000, a thousand,
2,000 of the comics.
Go to a Comic-Con.
Use online hashtags of
people that are interested.
Just give it away.
The attention's worth
more than anything else.
And I always say, watch what I do,
not what I say.
There's a reason I don't sell products.
There's a reason I don't have masterminds,
or e-books, or things of that nature.
I give away all my content for free
because your attention's more valuable
than extracting money from you.
So I would give away
the comic book at scale.
- [Man] Very good.
Next question, the last question,
number six comes from Pam.
She says what's the number
one piece of crap thinking
or behavior that gets up your nose?
She wants to know what this room needs
to hear to start doing
better in business and life.
- Man, I like you, Pam.
(laughing)
Pam, there's a lot, I mean, look,
there's so much...
I mean, look, the thing
that really drives me crazy,
and I just spoke to it, is entitlement.
Anybody here that thinks
anybody owes them anything
is already in deep shit.
Entitlement's stunning.
Number two, the thing, lack of patience.
It's why I push it so hard.
You want to make a million dollars a year
and you think that's supposed
to happen in the first
two three, four, five, seven
years of you doing something.
It's laughable.
People have gotten so crazy about the one
or two things like Uber and Instagram
without realizing that
it's, you're more likely
to win the lotto than start a
company that looks like that.
You're more likely to
get struck by lightening
seven times than starting
anything that looks like Uber
or Instagram.
So just people's perspective
is completely fucked.
I don't understand what
people are doing out here.
I don't know what it is in
Australia, look this up.
The median income levels
compared to what people
are aspiring to.
I America, if you make $440,000 a year,
you're in the 1% earners in
one of the richest countries
in the world.
If you make $440,000 a year in America,
you're in the 1%.
That's the bottom of the 1%,
but you're in the 1%.
Yet, everybody's walking around like,
if they don't make a million bucks,
they haven't even started doing anything.
And so, perspective, entitlement,
complete lack of patience.
This stuff is hard and
takes a lot of work.
Clearly, what gets in my nose,
which I like the way you put it,
is when we transition to this Q&A,
that I had a rant for two more minutes.
I can't wrap my head
around how many people
have consumed the same
shit from me 67 times,
in written form, in audio
form, in video form,
and in 88-page deck
form, in LinkedIn form.
I spend millions of dollars
saying the same fucking shit
in 400,000 ways, hoping today's
going to be the fucking day.
That fucking pisses me off, Pam.
(laughing)
(audience applauding)
- [Man] That was the last question.
So any last words?
You flew 36 hours.
You're here.
Any last words you want to give?
- That's a big sign.
Can I ask a question?
Yes, that's just, I have to
reward that ridiculous sign.
Go ahead.
(laughing)
I'll repeat it.
(speaking faintly off mic)
I'm here.
Come up here.
Let clap it up for Amir.
Yo, Amir's buddy, hold up
the sign that you guys made.
Stand up and hold it up.
It's such a piece of shit,
(audience laughs)
but it worked.
Come up here, Amir.
Bring your fucking sign.
This is perfect.
This is attention arbitrage.
I mean, how much did
this piece of shit cost?
Like, a dollar?
Look at this.
But it worked.
Good job.
What's your question?
(cheering)
Do you have a mic for him?
Or you can speak into my mic.
- [Man] Here, I'll give him mine.
- There we go.
- I'm currently 15 years old.
- 15?
- Yeah.
(cheering)
I skipped a day of school for this.
- That's a great decision.
- Yeah.
- Talk into this so they can hear you.
- My question is is there any chance
you can be my mentor?
- So, Jesus.
(audience laughs)
Definitely not.
Mainly on the back of I
don't even know how people,
I don't even talk to DRock.
I barely talk to my mom and my brother.
I don't want to stand up here in front of,
I don't care how much they aww and hum.
I've no interest in bullshitting you.
I think mentorship is
an interesting thing.
Here's what I would say for you.
One, especially, with me,
nobody is spending more time
and energy and resources
trying to show people
what to do.
It's literally like I'm
putting it out every day.
So mentorship, super-easy.
Number two, what I will
do is I'm more than happy
to give you a summer
internship on my team.
(audience cheering)
So if you can figure out
how to get to America,
I'm sure you will.
You made a fucking sign.
And so--
- [Man] Wouldn't use that as a boat.
- You can just get on that.
Happy to do that for you.
- Thanks.
- You're welcome, buddy.
Just send me an email.
It's gary@vaynermedia.com.
Good job.
Take care.
Come on.
DRock needs still shots these days.
I can sign it.
Hold this up.
DRock's been fucking bugging me.
(audience laughs)
Awesome, you got a pen?
- [Man] Here you go.
- Markers, nice.
Now, here's the most
important part of this.
You have to sell this on eBay.
(laughing)
Melbourne, I love you.
- [Man] Give him a hand.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Gary V!
- Do something!
So something, please!
Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
Even you.
Thank you.